yeah
[Music]
Paris reverberated
to the sights sounds and smells of
conflict
more than a hundred thousand people took
to the streets in the city
the annual demonstration to Mark workers
rights this year peppered with political
Fury about pension reforms
this was the 13th in a long line of
protests
there were constant battles with the
right police who snatched targets out of
the crowd
and used tear gas relentlessly
and in return they were attacked
constantly here an injured officer
carried to safety one of more than a
hundred hurt across the country
in Lyon cars set on fire there were
running battles in other cities
the protest was everywhere enveloping
the country
and the focus of all this anger was the
president Emmanuel macron
who's overridden Parliament to push
through his reform program posed by the
great majority of his Nation he won the
election yes but is he still legitimate
and the art is this reforms legitimate I
don't think so no there's a there's
different way for people to express
their opinion and the street is one of
them
the violence was mainly instigated by
the so-called Black Block groups here
simply to incite conflict
here smoke billowing from fires started
deliberately at Place de la nacion one
of the city's main gateways well these
Mayday protests in France are often
combustible volatile and violent Affairs
but this is one is different because
there's a focal point to all this anger
and that is Emmanuel macron
macron's opponents have always alleged
he is aloof and out of touch now the
criticism seems endemic even among those
who voted for him
Macon can see here and sense this Fury
but he's showing no sign of changing his
mind his hope is that all this will
dissipate but this is an angry country
reconciliation won't come easily